what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch Mortal Kombat 11
Kombat pack official roster reveal
trailer pretty sure this is courtesy of
games con but before we do that I wanted
to give a special special thank you to
raid shadow legends for being a sponsor
on the channel for this month
if you don't know raid is one of the
most ambitious immersive and highly
rated mobile games available right now
and the best part is it's totally free
for iOS and Android ray takes all your
favorite elements of a turn-based RPG
and updates them with cinematic camera
angles and beautifully rendered 3d
graphics as well as a rich storyline
massive boss and PvP battles collectible
and upgradable characters and a brand
new daily login rewards program it's one
of the most immersive experience it's
available for your smartphone and the
game really does have something for
everyone so hit that link in the
description box to download raid and
join over 10 million players worldwide
and get 50k gold plus a free epic
champion just for downloading
some how it looks just like the movie No
baby
clown princess bride that's cool
not gonna lie told you I knew spawn was
in this I did not register that the
Terminator was in this dude that was
wicked for a second I almost thought it
was gonna be like John wick or something
but but Terminator that's pretty freakin
sweet yeah especially for mortal combat
like just imagine the spine ripping and
this a crazy laser beaming you can do
obviously not as familiar with Nightwolf
or as Sindel as we ought to be but very
familiar with Shang Tsung played by
Kerry Hiroyuki tagua who I met once he
signed something for me which I have
definitely lost this time tattooed on
it's interesting to have the Shang Tsung
character be born in the video game and
take DLC character and model him after
the movie version that's so cool just
goes to show you how much people love
that Mortal Kombat movie I was on the
screen junkies news fandom Entertainment
last week and we talked pretty in-depth
about the new Mortal Kombat movie really
dawned on me you know even though
there's an argument for like what is the
best video game movie Angry Birds to
getting the highest reviewed video game
results on Rotten Tomatoes or video game
annotation Mortal Kombat still takes to
the Fermi even beyond detective Pikachu
and Tomb Raider and like Knotts the
Mortal Kombat to me you feel like moving
on bat hit at the right time and was the
right thing for what it was yeah somehow
like and also to like for its time the
realization of like Goro and stuff yeah
it's pretty impressive even still I
still hold Silent Hill to be my favorite
video game movie but I'll give you
Mortal Kombat in a close second sure
sure and this Terminator t800 is this
modeled after the Genesis or dark fate
Terminator I was born about to because I
thought of Genesis when he came out but
I'm hoping then maybe it'll be
I barely remember Genisys I don't
remember if you had facial hair in it
but I know in dark fate he has facial
when does Dark Fae drop I don't remember
that scene in the trailer for Janus
facial does he then Genesis when he
smiles it's like I think he's
clean-shaven even as old Arnold either
way I mean you got Arnold and Teja
that's gonna be like my go-to character
right there and it makes sense how you
can infuse Joker into here because the
developers worked on injustice and Joker
is a surprisingly awesome player to use
when I pick up him as a character and I
kick a lot of ass with him so having the
Joker there's awesome clothes cool
design on him you know he's got the
Conan hair so yeah a little bit of the
young like Leto Joker but still like
kind of menacing and suave and then to
have spawn in here with all the hype
coming out with a new movie this is just
right timing is everything like the
release dates are great market is you
got available now which shanks on a
night wolf and Terminator
I think dark fate comes out in November
so perfect absolutely perfect
advertising because this is October when
you get t800 Sindel kiddin provide no
commentary for Joker more Joker movie
promo as well and then spot I don't know
when that movies coming out but people
are eagerly awaiting when that footage
comes out you know my guess is it's
April
but I bet you out of all these spawn
will probably be the one the best one to
use just that's the most exciting to me
just yeah for like the range of hellish
things you might be able to do you know
in the fantasy aspect of it this is a
really crazy lineup I mean just look
here we have the photo frozen on screen
I'm just looking at them I want to play
I don't want to play all those all them
yeah nightwolf I want to learn a little
bit more about night I mean you know
sits in Della's is you know another
attractive video game fighting character
that's all I know about that but night
wolf I was looking at him I was like
aura plays this guy I don't know it was
Tarak for a second oh yeah isn't that I
think night wolf as a mortal kombat
character I was gonna say that seems
like he would be yeah he seems like
something out of a fighter specifically
but I don't know I wonder how much more
like that this has to be just the tip of
the iceberg in terms of doing actor
portrayal versions of
certain characters are bringing in other
like famous movies like the Arnold looks
like motion capture Arnold they're like
I think we'll probably start to see more
and more of those like you know maybe
we'll get a Stallone character and one
of these fighting games maybe we'll get
you know all these wrestling guys like
John Cena video games for Terminator 2
and matrix to be Tom and Matt you've got
neo in there dude buddy you and Keanu
John wick yeah but the fact that they
got you know Arnold in here it could
have easily just been like two hundred
exoskeleton mmm but Vince xover endo
endo and because the XO would be
anything else yes and t800 endoskeleton
I think it was really smart of them to
actually use Arnold instead already than
just the Terminator whoo yeah oh yeah
and that's gonna get people jacked plus
I wonder what the physics are gonna be
like too if like his skin old ship like
things like that especially with how
complicated yes have gotten always
excite me and like what their special
moves are gonna be I wonder how they
decide who to put in here it's like you
can just vote for people let's see like
ash from little devil dad to be infused
in here obviously we we've opted for
Keanu Reeves from one of the versions of
ki on let's get SATA Co from the ring
I'm you come out you know you could do
like some special attack with your hair
or whatever and I can leave people with
it at the end well this looks great man
Mortal Kombat you guys always deliver I
don't play any storyline in Mortal
Kombat let's go to my friend Tony's
place and we would just bite each other
for two hours yeah do you think when the
new movie comes out they'll have a James
Wan DLC character what just James one of
the Mortal Kombat
yeah oh yeah movies yeah oh man when
they get the movie to come out because
that's going through hello development
right now this is actually happening I
can't wait to see like whoever the fan
favorite characters are and that they
put them like they Mahlum after that
because they have
Sub Zero already cast so I wonder if
they'll take that movie I'm sure they
will take a dlc version of Sub Zero
from the from the latest movie or like
the Lu King yeah they got him cast as
well so you might get that probably
easier models and sub-zero usually wears
a mask that would be underneath the mask
that never comes off he looks just like
the actor it's freezing alright guys
well I can't wait to play can't wait for
some gameplay trade me when those
gameplay trailers drop make sure to let
us know because I would love to see
especially for the ones that we've
talked more in depth about guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bow so you get
notified whenever we got a video wow
thank you again to rage shadow legends
for working with us this month hit that
link like to give a picture today shot
to a man named Scuba Steve Scuba Steve
is a wonderful artist he does a lot of
illegal graffiti art which you can catch
on his youtube channel Scuba Steve films
he's constantly recording videos now he
just passed 200 subscribers slowly but
surely
growing a hell of a lot but seriously
they're great videos if you like or fede
art I think you'd really dig these in
the videos super advertiser friendly I
have this markdown but I don't really
remember if this is accurate I've put
down that your birthday was on August
19th oh it is happy may be birthday it's
your birthday happy birthday I'm just
not sure and if it's not happy birthday
in advance or happy belated birthday
yes you know happy next to your burst
happy all of your birthdays so you
should you should go to a strip club and
spray-paint one of those chicks Oh
they'd love do it for like 10 bucks
easily trust me yeah make it rain grill
on paint paint paint paint rain